we were having the debate all morning
what is the best Quentin Tarantino movie
you don't do you think like that do you
look back on your career and say
this is the defining movie of my life
it's the best I did you know for years
people used to ask me stuff like that
and then I would usually say something
well they're all like my children
then I would change it to well it kind
of depends on when you ask me if you ask
me one year or one moment I could say oh
Kill Bill another one I could say
something else but I really do think
once upon a time in Hollywood is my best
movie when you watch your own movies
back or I don't know if you do but yeah
when you you do yeah when when you um
why do you watch your own movies back I
love you you'll love them I love my
movies
everybody else is invited all right
anytime when movies are on like on the
yeah on TV I'm like oh hey oh well I
guess uh now I'm watching Jackie Brown
for a while I think that's such an
honest answer because I you know you
talk to actors oh I never watch anything
I do and uh or or film that no no no I
can't it's too painful no you like these
moves I'm very I'm not them I'm very
happy with my work
thank you